[Musica]
Allora ho a disposizione 12 minuti e per
quanto i tempi brevi non mi appartengono
proverò a riuscirci
Allora quella che sto per raccontarvi la
mia storia vuole solo testimoniare come
nella vita il cambio di prospettiva a
volte sia fondamentale come nella vita
Se si adotta l'atteggiamento mentale e
la filosofia giusta ci sono davvero
poche cose che non si possono realizzare
e ancora se alleniamo la nostra mente ad
acquisire un po' di elasticità molte o
quasi tutte le situazioni
apparentemente negative possono
trasformarsi in positive e interessanti
cominciamo
trascorro un'infanzia in adolescenza
normale finché poco prima dei 17 anni
subisca un brutto incidente di moto
vengo investito da una macchina e mi
fratturo tibia e perone di entrambe le
gambe Ma la ferita la gamba destra è
particolarmente grave tant'è che rischio
l'amputazione dell'arto questa era la
mia Gambetta
all'epoca
trascorro 13 mesi tra ospedali
interventi chirurgici laser
riabilitazione
fissatori esterni finché non si risolve
tutto bene però l'evento è
potenzialmente negativo ma dicevamo va
tutto bene e l'assicurazione mi liquida
al danno con 30 milioni delle vecchie
lire che nel 1983 non sono molti ma
neanche pochi
Dopodiché superato l'incidente finisco
il liceo linguistico faccio il servizio
militare E qualche lavoretto per avere
un minimo di indipendenza economica ma è
direi verso i 21 anni che intuisco ciò
che nella vita mi piace allora amo stare
in mezzo alla gente mi piace comunicare
e mi sento particolarmente attratto
dalle donne
particolarmente attratto dalle donne
mi specializzo in qualche modo e divento
e lavoro come barman in discoteca sulla
Riviera Adriatica vengo a sapere In
quegli anni che un locale vuole dare la
gestione quindi non ho
tutta la cifra a disposizione però
insieme a un mio amico decidiamo di
tentare il grande passo Quindi metto sul
piatto i 30 milioni
dell'incidente che nel frattempo non
avevo toccato chiedo un prestito in
banca fissiamo un pagamento rateale nel
tempo e io il mio amico abbiamo la
discoteca funziona tutto bene per tre
anni e mezzo finché all'inizio degli
anni 90 il turismo non cambia mentre
prima per buona parte dell'Europa il
mare significava arrivare sulle coste
italiane
all'inizio di quegli anni iniziano
arrivare i primi voli low cost aprendo
nuove destinazioni e quindi tedeschi
olandesi svedesi che prima venivano da
noi cominciano ad andare in Spagna in
Grecia in Egitto
il turismo ha un drastico calo e io in
qualche modo mi trovo costretto a
svendere la mia quota ma nel tempo
sarebbe stato sempre peggio e rientro a
malapena dei miei 30 milioni iniziali
evento potenzialmente negativo ma
quell'esperienza mi rende un po' più
sicuro di me Diciamo che dal punto di
vista dell'osare non ha più paura di
niente e nel frattempo ho conosciuto
anche in senso biblico molte ragazze di
nazioni straniere quindi la mia
confidenza con l'universo femminile era
notevolmente aumentata ok
Non ho più la discoteca sono libero
e penso che vorrei fare un lavoro che mi
consenta di viaggiare mi faccia fare
sport mi faccia stare al caldo tutto
l'anno e mi agevole ancora una volta nel
rapporto con lo stesso femminile altre
richieste quello volevo fare penso un
po' Eccola qua animatore sportivo nei
villaggi turistici Tac
divento rara foto coi capelli
di vento istruttore di tiro con l'arco
sport che già praticavo e parto per i
villaggi quindi Sardegna Calabria
Maldive Caraibi Dopo la quinta stagione
di vento capo Sport quindi responsabile
degli altri istruttori sportivi e dopo
la sesta stagione Vorrei diventare capo
villaggio sento che è una cosa che
vorrei fare e sono sicuro che la società
me lo proporrà perché ho lavorato bene
Ho lavorato con passione ma
questo non succede Mi dicono che non
sono abbastanza bravo e che non sono
ancora pronto
evento potenzialmente negativo perché io
proprio ci credevo l'avrei voluto fare
Ci rimango malissimo
talmente male che decido che quella in
corso sarà la mia ultima stagione nei
villaggi ma
proprio durante quell'estate conosco lo
sponsor di un importante premio per il
cinema il premio Campidoglio a Roma
che quell'anno avrebbe premiato il mio
attore del cuore il mio attore favorito
quella che quello che era sempre stato
il mio idolo quindi a settembre ormai a
fine stagione non potrei ma mi in punto
e prendo tre giorni di permesso dalla
Calabria dove stava lavorando vado a
Roma vado a Roma perché voglio
incontrare questo attore che per me è
speciale incontro
Clint Eastwood
presentava all'epoca i ponti di Madison
County
ci troviamo incredibilmente Grazie allo
sponsor che avevo conosciuto soltanto io
e lui per qualche secondo in un giardino
prima di un party in suo onore
gli stringo la mano allora non c'erano
ancora i selfie e gli faccio
semplicemente i complimenti per i suoi
film
è il 1995 o 28 anni e ho l'illuminazione
Allora mi dico Ma anziché trovare sempre
dei lavori che ti agevolino nel fare
sesso con le donne Perché non fai
direttamente sesso per mestiere
sempre che ne avesse avuto le capacità
ora non so in quanti lo sanno Ma fare il
pornoattore professionista è abbastanza
complicato per mille motivi ma
quell'incontro col Divo del cinema
mondiale era come se mi avesse dato una
carica particolare Era come se quella
stretta di mano ne avesse comunicato
un'energia così una sorta di superpoteri
quindi Ok non me ne frega niente di
quello che penserà la gente Prova a
diventare un porno attore professionista
Cerco in tutti i modi di contattare
registri e produttori faccio qualche
provino e nel 1997 inizia la mia
carriera da porno divo la pornoattore
all'inizio ti vedevo un po' di colleghe
belle e brave
Spero che le guardiate volentieri anche
voi
e sono anni di grande successo Non solo
mio personale ma di tutto il settore
perché il porno ha influenzato E
influenza costume società e milioni di
persone non c'era una casa in cui
nascosta da qualche parte non c'era un
VHS o un DVD porno diciamo la verità ma
arriva lo sapete prepotente internet
con annessa pirateria produzione a costi
zero e video fai da te in pochi anni è
la fine di gran parte delle produzioni
delle distribuzioni delle videoteche
dei tecnici degli addetti ai lavori
insomma un disastro evento
potenzialmente negativo ma
nel frattempo mi si era aperta la porta
della televisione
alla quale seguì la radio alla quale
seguì il teatro ma dopo un po'
decido di fare altro perché sono una
persona che si annoia abbastanza
facilmente qui vedete grande onore con
Giancarlo Giannini una piccola parte
la talpa qualcuno di voi se lo ricorderà
reality record di ascolti di Italia 1 e
inizio a scrivere libri così per variare
per cambiare libri che ovviamente
all'inizio nessuno voleva pubblicare
e mi metto a disposizione come mental
coach arrivando in qualche modo ai
giorni odierna Allora io mi sono chiesto
nel tempo
come sia stato possibile tutta questa
serie di eventi favorevoli di
coincidenze straordinarie e pur non
essendo un genio Non sono affatto un
genio ma credo di aver capito un po'
come funziona e vi fornisco la mia
semplicissima formula ma il fatto che
sia semplice non vuol dire che sia
assolutamente efficace rapidamente
la mia ricetta riflettere riflettiamo
perché ogni scelta che noi facciamo ha
una conseguenza nel bene e nel male il
famoso effetto Domino
fare qualcosa senza riflettere Per me
sarebbe come andare in barca a vela in
mezzo all'oceano senza conoscere le
correnti senza conoscere il mare e senza
avere la bussola così a cieca riflettere
non vuol dire essere timorose di fare le
cose ma semplicemente pensare un attimo
prima di
avere una mente elastica quand'è che si
invecchia fondamentalmente quando si
perde di elasticità fisica o mentale e
quindi una mente elastica ci può aiutare
a rimanere
cioè come dicevano prima non è mai tutto
bianco tutto nero tutto bello tutto
brutto posso bere qualcosa come se lecca
la lingua che come funziona in questi
casi posso Sì adesso ci sono le riprese
Ma no
[Applauso]
il potere Il potere della mente Io ho
detto ma di solito quando mangio prima
di fare uno speech mi si secca la gola
l'ho detto e ciò succede
il potere di ciò che diciamo
quindi la mente elastica per farci
capire che non abbiamo mai Assolutamente
torto ma assolutamente ragione Terzo
punto sta per fare qualcosa bene saper
fare qualcosa molto bene perché su
questo Costruiamo il pilastro della
nostra autostima Su questo possiamo è il
nostro biglietto da visita e il nostro
punto di forza e può essere la nostra
zattera di salvataggio quando c'è un
momento di crisi ci dà proprio una
un'identità poi uno può cambiare come la
mia storia dimostra un po' di coraggio
un po' di coraggio Cioè nella maggior
parte dei casi non succede niente Non
dico di rischiare la vita tutti i giorni
però però
usiamo tentiamo di fare qualcosa che ci
piace chi se ne frega anche perché ho
letto su Internet che si vive una volta
sola e siccome internet ci prende sempre
pare che sia così
esempio rapido Penso che tutti voi o
buona parte di voi legga dei romanzi
Pensate un romanzo in cui va sempre
tutto bene tutto perfetto tutti felici
tutti contenti che palle cioè un romanzo
Quand'è che prende vita quando c'è un
imprevisto quando c'è un problema da
affrontare quando c'è una difficoltà e
allora se ci appassiona in un romanzo
perché dovrebbe spaventarci nella vita
posto che non la restiamo
Infine forse il punto più importante il
bicchiere mezzo pieno perché il
bicchiere mezzo pieno perché ci abitua a
concentrarci sul positivo e non sul
negativo perché ci mette in uno stato di
gratitudine
Pensate se noi chiediamo sempre qualcosa
alla vita no gli chiediamo in qualche
modo Chiediamo la vita di darci XY
pensate alla vita come una persona
l'universo è come una persona se questa
persona vi dà qualcosa vi concede un
aiuto
noi però non la ringraziamo mai Ok Dammi
questo l'ho avuto questo no ok però
quest'altro Sì non la ringraziamo mai
se la vita e l'universo fosse una
persona senza essere mai ringraziata
quanto tempo ancora continuerebbe ad
aiutarvi quindi è importante essere
grati infine
partire dal bicchiere mezzo pieno vuol
dire partire da uno stato di
insoddisfazione piuttosto che di
insoddisfazione e l'insoddisfazione
attrae altra
insoddisfazione mentre la soddisfazione
attrae quasi sempre soddisfazione
Ultimamente ho scritto uno spettacolo
comico teatrale
Master sex con uno stand up comedian
molto bravo e sono molto contento sono
molto fiducioso perché mi hanno
comunicato proprio in questi giorni che
due importanti rassegne teatrali non
vogliono lo spettacolo perché ci sono io
evento potenzialmente negativo vedremo
cosa succede Grazie
[Applauso]